so it's a pleasure to introduce Sascha
Rocklin he he he sent some very generic
title a few connections between
optimization probability but I see that
he changed the slides okay so thanks for
the invitation pleasure to speak here
this is actually kind of a continuation
of the bootcamp talk that I gave in
September I will describe this
Burkholder method which I think should
be more widely known within the
communities of online learning and the
optimization community and but let me
first motivate and let me say that this
is ongoing work with Dylan Foster and
Karthik's later on let me
first provide the motivation for this
problem the motivation is online
supervised learning so we have a very
genetic prediction problem prediction
task that lasts for n rounds at each
round t we observe some site information
XT think of this as a vector or a matrix
we make a prediction a real valid
prediction y hat T and then we observe
the outcome YT and so what we would like
to do is we would like to have a few
mistakes or a small number of errors
accumulated over and rounds and so
that's going to be measured by the
following regret inequality so let me
decode this on the left hand side we
have a cumulative error that we incur
over n rounds and what we would like to
have is that it's not much more than the
minimum of the kind of the linear
explanation of Y from X so the the fit
to data in hindsight and I'm using
absolute values rather than square loss
for simplicity here and so that's the
first term if indeed the sequence that
will come has a good explanation of why
for max in terms of a linear prediction
then this term is going to be small and
there is another term that adapts to the
difficulty of the sequence so some
sequences and thus just a function of
the X's are difficult and so we would
allow more error on those sequences and
some sequences are nicer and would like
fewer errors on those sequences and the
key property here is that we would like
this result to hold for all sequences
we're not assuming any generative
process on the data would like the
method to be robust with respect to any
miss specification and and have it for
all sequences okay so it's not clear
that this is even possible but it turns
out that kind of one can develop methods
that enjoy this inequality for all
sequences and without without explaining
too much let me just say that the best
measure of the difficulty of the X
sequence in this case is what's called
the empirical Rademacher complexity so
given the covariance X 1 through X and
you form you look at the norm without
specifying what the norm is the norm of
the sum of these vectors or matrices
multiplied by random coin flips random
random signs right so this measures some
some what matters the spread of the XS
if you wish and one can show that this
is the best one can do in this setting
an easy lower bound shows this one
example that I would like you to have in
mind is matrix completion so this is a
case where both W and X are matrices one
by one you're predicting entries of a
matrix in this case XT is just the
indicator it's a zero matrix with an
indicator where you need to make the
next prediction that's the site
information you make the next prediction
y hat t you observe the outcome and at
the end of the day you're hoping that
there is going to be a low rank or low
trace norm explanation of the observed
outcomes given by some low rank or low
trace in our matrix okay
cien should technically depend on F as
well it will not depend on O on this F
yes yes sorry I didn't write it write F
typically is going to be some kind of
wall in some space you can also make C
and depend on W but this is not what
we're gonna do but typically good
genetically you could go into that into
that direction okay so okay so the
question that is this possible that's
the motivation right is this possible to
obtain this bound let me also say that
if you get this this is like a ninja
bounded call a ninja bound because if at
the end of the day you you actually do
have iid data XY z-- or iid and then if
you just average the trajectory then you
get the optimal result in the IAD case
as well because empirical Rademacher is
the optimal bound for the problem
prediction with absolute value loss
right but here we're trying to get it
for all sequences not just for iid
sequences okay so kind of what do you do
well kind of the the first thing that
you try to do is you turn to online
comics optimization you treat this as a
sum ft of vector W and now if you're
making proper predictions these are
predictions that are based on some
estimate WT that you keep updating over
the rounds then you can think of this as
FG of WT and now this becomes what's
called an online convex optimization
problem you observe these functions ft
coming and and and you make a gradient
step typically now what kind of C n can
you get if you do gradient descent then
well if you do gradient a mirror just
sent with an adaptive step size then
what you can get is a square root of the
sum of the squares of the gradients
right this is a bound that depends on
the actual sequence of the of the
functions and of course for our case
that's just the norms of the X's right
squared all right so what you can get
with this result with gradient descent
or mirror just
with adaptive step size is square root
of the sum of the squares now if you
look at the gap between what we want and
which is the Rademacher averages and the
square root of the sum of the squares
you observe that there could be a huge
gap right in the l2 case where this is a
Euclidean norm there is no gap from the
kitchen Kahane inequality these are up
to constant height but in different
geometries there could be a huge gap and
in particular if you do a matrix
completion and you replace the rank with
an appropriate trace norm bound this one
is meaningless this bound becomes
meaningless because you are essentially
taking every entry and taking a norm of
that matrix rather the zero matrix with
just one entry on and a norm of that is
just going to be a constant so you're
paying for every every time step and and
here this is a spectral norm in that
case of a random matrix and that has a
much nicer behavior and it has a
behavior that's driven by you know the
spread of the axis how the sampling is
done for the matrix completion problem
okay so the question is how do we fix
this issue it seems like the gradient
descent cannot give us the result that
we want it's a product of the so there
is rows and columns and if you replace
the rank are constrained with an
appropriate race time constraint is
going to be square root of the product
of the dimensions and you get another
square root of the product of the
dimensions from this and so the CN
becomes just a constant or grows
linearly with the product of the
dimensions of the matrix
so the question is how to fix this gap
whether there exists a method that gets
this bound instead of this bound and
what I would like to claim is that so I
know that Alexander Madhuri is giving a
talk that the gradient descent is the
mother of all algorithms I'm gonna claim
that the the well maybe there is a
father but it's not manat going to be
enough for our purposes somehow there is
a fundamental difficulty with gradient
descent or a marriage ascent in this in
that it's not keeping the right
statistics about the sequence that
observes right yes that's the claim
great in the center mirror descent oh so
we know that it's parameterised by a
strongly convex function you take you
your geometry is given by a norm and
that now you come up with a strongly
convex function with respect to that
norm I then you define a brakeman
divergence right underneath that gives
you the mirror descent right
so the basic primitive in this
construction of mirror descent is a
strongly convex function right so
strongly convex function is the
geometric notion that you're exploiting
when you do gradient descent or mirror
descent and the claim is that we need a
different geometric notion the question
is which one so this is what I said we
need additional information about the
geometry of the functions not just the
size of the gradients which is what
emerges and keeps in memory but the
somehow they're spread of the gradients
and the question is can we go beyond the
usual notions of smoothness and strong
convexity in the in the TCS community I
know that there is a lot of work
applying first order methods to a
variety of problems there has been a lot
of progress by using the right geometry
and and and hopefully ideas from from
this Burkholder method can be also
translated into
and into that setting okay now we would
be searching in the dark for the right
geometry notion for the right primitive
if not for the following connections
which I think are fundamental and so
even if it doesn't really make sense I
will try to at least sketch them we
start with the problem of online
prediction and then when we go to the
minimax duel
for that problem when we write it as a
as a as a two-player game and we appeal
to the 1/9 and minimax theorem we get a
martingale a certain set of martingale
inequalities that we need to certify
this is something that we started with
Peter Bartlett in 2009 I get 2008 what I
would like to talk about now is a
connection between martingale and
equalities and geometry and once we
understand both this connection and that
connection we will be able to go back
and use the geometric primitive for
online prediction that's kind of the
overall goal so there is there's a there
are two fundamental connections here I
will not talk about this one I will just
talk about the Burkholder connection
okay
so let me describe the Burkholder method
and if you want more information things
can get very difficult very quickly my
goal is to present the simplest possible
explanation to the point that you'll
probably say that it's trivial if you
want more information here's the very
nice book by Adam osakowski who is the
expert on this subject he has written
many many many papers and many
expositions of the method and what we
would like to do is just to adapt some
of these ideas to our setting in the
simplest way possible okay
so let me introduce a little bit of the
notation Epsilon's are IID Rademacher
coin flips plus minus 150 50 ft is just
going to be the Sigma algebra generated
by the first T random coin flips and X
is a martingale different sequence with
respect to this filtration does the
attic filtration so the expected value
of XT given the FT minus 1 is equal to 0
and just a side note any of this any
diuretic marking gilliam of this form
can be written in fact as a epsilon T
times some function of the past coin
flips right and that just follows from
the fact that it has to be 0 and there
are only two possibilities because
epsilon T takes on two values right so
conditioning conditioning on these
absalon's there are only two
possibilities you can always write it in
this form this is a martingale
increments martingale differences for
some predictable function XT any
questions please stop me if something
doesn't make sense
okay so we talked about martingale
inequalities what are these martingale
inequalities well we can write one
genetically very genetically as some
function B of the martingale different
sequence of length N and just say that
the expected value of this B is less
than zero so this covers a lot when you
choose the right B you get a martingale
inequality right
choose your favorite B and try to prove
this or if you observe some martingale
in equality you can convert it into this
form I'm going to abuse notation and B
will will have a different size inputs
right so it's just a function from the
union of the X to the N for all M right
so this should be for all M any
questions about this
so here is a statement I I were writing
this up but you know this is really the
Burkholder method so there is just
specified a little bit to our setup the
result is that one holds that's a
martingale inequality it holds for all
martingale different sequences and all M
if and only if there exists a function
satisfying certain properties so already
at this point you should you should
start wondering why this is possible
this is a statement in probability and
expectation and this is a statement
about the existence of some function and
the claim is that from this existence we
can deduce certain geometry that we need
to use the this function will satisfy
properties that I will describe in a
second
that will induce certain geometry but
which B is given B is given and this
holds for all martingales if and only if
there exists some function you
okay so what are these properties first
is the property that connects you to be
and it's just the domination so you is
larger than B that's all that's the only
connection between you and B the second
one is you of the empty set because it
takes on different length inputs you
have the empty set is less than zero so
that's kind of a shift and the third one
is the most important one if if you take
any inputs and then you average over the
in the last coordinate over X T and
minus X team remember XT is can be
vectors or matrices or whatever it has
to be upper bounded by you of the you
know with one less three conditions very
very simple conditions right and the
claim is that that holding for all
martingale different signals is
equivalent to existence of a function
with these properties and in particular
if you can get a hold on a function with
these properties it allows you to prove
that inequality so in particularly if
you can dream up a function of find it
using SOS or whatever you want with
these properties you've proved a a
martingale inequality and that could
have been possibly difficult to prove
otherwise
any questions about this statement
and the proof is actually very simple so
let me do the easy direction first
suppose that you have a function you
with all these properties well this one
is the domination condition and now you
repeatedly apply the third condition
which removes the coordinate one by one
and then you end up with you of the
empty set and that's above that's upper
bounded by zero right so there is no
difficulty here just a slightly more
difficult is the other direction and
this is where burkholder's contribution
comes in he recognized that if you
defined you using the following
definition then it satisfies the
properties that I've listed so this
requires just a few more steps
but it's also not difficult to prove so
what is this definition you want to find
U of some length input X 1 through X T
the way that you're going to define it
as a supremum over any n up to which you
go and any marking yield difference from
xt plus 1 to n and now you look at the
expected value of b with this random
continuation right so essentially the
way that you define the u u function the
optimal u star function is by a random
continuation right think of this as a
random walk or and this make some kind
of smoothing of the B function if you
wish mmm might be some connections to in
in that direction okay it's not
difficult to I'm not gonna show it but
it's not difficult to show it's just a
few lines
supreme is with respect to all lengths
and these are the random continuations
and all possible martingale martingale
different sequences
which one is the one you you're gonna be
using those though which one we're going
to be using for directions well both
actually gonna be using both I will give
two examples yep so the first example
will be the one that will cherish and
love which is a strong strong convexity
right as a consequence of this and the
second one is this other statistic that
you need to keep in my memory to get the
Rademacher bound that I enjoyed okay
so easy to show that you star is the
smallest function that satisfies this
even though it's defined as a supremum
it's the smallest function that
satisfies these three properties and the
first two are trivial the only thing to
check is the third one and indeed
suppose that you have a well this is
just the you have a you prime function
that satisfies the condition this is the
what was the first condition the
domination condition and this is the
third condition and because the U star
is defined as the supremo of the left
hand side you've got the result right so
that's easy to check yeah I'm trying to
make it as trivial as possible
okay so now we come to examples example
one smoothness and strong convexity it
turns out that the inequality that
corresponds the martingale inequality
that corresponds to strong due to
smoothness I should say is this
inequality right so what is this this is
a random walk you measure the length
squared of the random walk in the in the
in some norm and now you want to see how
it's related to the expected norm
squared of the increments of the random
walk right if it's Euclidean norm this
is just the equality right you open up
the square cross terms cancel the claim
is that this is the the inequality that
corresponds to smoothness right once
you've got smoothness you can define
strong convexity then from strong
convexity define the brakeman divergence
you define mirrored descent okay so what
is the B function it's a function of two
statistics right clear that you need
write the the B function is just a
function of two statistics one is the
sum of the x's and the other one is the
sum of the squares right and once you
write it like that it's clear that what
we want is expected be less than zero
right here what we want is expected be
less than zero what is this function
that that certifies this well it exists
because we know that if the norm is
smooth you can prove the inequality so
if if you can prove the inequality then
then this U star exists so one more
thing is that u star inherits this
property that u star of X and this is a
constant alpha squared is just U star of
X zero minus K alpha squared you can
just check it from the definition and
you can also check that the third
property can be written in a slightly
nicer form as this inequality okay
so you just have to search over these
functions over functions that satisfy
the first two inequalities and this
inequality you can run over all the
space of all functions and as a
corollary of this observation and this
observation you see that you can show I
can show it in the next slide that the
function X to u star of X 0 is a
universal smooth function with respect
to the norm right so you give me a norm
this will be the smooth function that
you can construct and its dual is
strongly convex right so you give L
infinity normal a one norm I can
construct a smooth function just from
this U star and this is universal
construction is actually goes back to
PCEHR a long time ago Karthik has it in
his thesis written in a nice way but
actually it's much simpler it's just the
consequence of the third property it's
just a consequence of this third problem
right the interesting thing is that the
the this existence of a smooth function
follows from concavity right you can
treat this as a concavity property of
this optimal U star function okay maybe
I don't have the time but the proof is
is three lines it's just by definition
and by that observation this be yes
so what is the question for me Radisson
that will be the case but in the play
setting we want it's not because we have
this random signs you need more let me
go to the second example maybe maybe you
see this okay okay so example two is how
to get this empirical Rademacher as the
regret bound so well it's it's not
definition your question is is it
entropy or is it or is it the LP norm
would be close to 1 no they're all
equivalent to up to a constant right so
I don't think you can just say that this
is that function it's a function and
it's equivalent to all other functions
but it's a universal construction ok so
now there's this three part connection
right so we need to take the we need to
look at the online problem look at its
dual the minimax dual to understand what
kind of marketing inequality we need to
to prove and the marking the only
quality that comes up is this one I'm
skipping something the one that comes up
is with P equal to 1 but we need to take
it with P larger than 1 but that that's
a minor minor issue let me explain what
this is this is exactly the original
dyadic martingale right I said that it
can be always written as epsilon G times
the predictable function of the past
right and now what you're asking is can
I decouple can I take the epsilon cheese
and just decouple them make a draw an
independent sequence of Epsilon's keep
the XTS measurable with respect to the
original sequence of Epsilon's but these
epsilon teaser
are decoupled all right so that's called
the decoupling inequality and it's not
clear that such an inequality would hold
but that's a martingale equality that we
need to to establish there is a if you
actually require a two-sided version of
this so that there is also lower bound
in terms of that this is known to be
equivalent to what's called the
deterministic property and the only
difference is that the it has to hold
for all sequences of coin flips and I
know that I'm going very fast here but
this is the inequality in fact that
we're going to be using it's again it's
a martingale inequality X teaser now the
dyadic martingales and these are fixed
signs and it's easy to write down the d
function for that and you see that it
has to keep these statistics right these
are statistics that are not kept by the
mirror descent or gradient descent and
once you keep these statistics that's
the B function there exists a u function
and sometimes we can compute it
sometimes we cannot compute it it's
neither convex nor concave the third
property translates into the following
property which is called zigzag
concavity in the literature and that's
an example of this u function and now we
can go back as I promised go back from
the geometry as given by this u function
go back to online prediction and define
a prediction method that attains the
Rademacher bound how do we do it
well we we linearize the problem this is
just a minor step this is the inequality
that we want to prove without the P but
okay so so let me skip this the step
that's upper bounded by the by the first
property because this is the B function
right so the B function is upper bounded
by the U function and so this is the
potential that we're going to be using
in our recursion for on the online
prediction problem and solving this
recursion that the last step tells you
what to do at the previous steps as well
in terms of prediction and you're just
taking a
radiant of the of you function at zero
as your prediction and if that's the
case there is a clean recursion that
happens and you essentially obtain the
regret bound with the Rademacher okay so
if you can get a handle on this you
function
you've got the result right so it's not
just the existence proof if you've got
this you function that's the one you
should be using to obtain the result
just the same way that you would be
using strong convexity if you thought
that the mirror just sent is what you
want okay so I think that's it I think
there is a very interesting set of
connections that can be exploited I
talked about the connection between
geometric properties of the space or the
the properties of this function promised
by the Burkholder method and the
connection to marking on equalities but
the online learning or online
optimization plays a crucial role here
because we understand what inequality is
to get by looking at the dual of this
problem
okay so just conclusion gradient descent
mirror descent does not keep the right
statistics about the sequence and and
the the geometric primitives of a strong
convexity or smoothness is not enough
and and so we can get the right result
by exploiting connections between
probabilistic and equalities and
geometry thank you questions
I wonder so this one is special cases
where he's not independent but American
inequality proves works as is with
martingale differences you don't need
the independence so it says that if the
norm is smooth and now you do mirror
descent then you can prove that new
mirror of skin equality right so that
that's one of the directions right the
interesting direction is is actually the
well I mean that's also an interesting
direction but it's that reverse that if
you could prove it then there must exist
the strongly convex function right yes
so the basis matrix conclusion actually
so we're trying to search we're trying
to get Pablo to find us this u function
for the spectral norm and let's see well
the kind of the the immediate thing to
do to tries to just try so s and try to
find it right approximate we don't need
the optimal one right we just need a
function that satisfy these properties
which you can all encode there's a
source right
so somebody really needs it you know
that this man getting what you whole
it's like for this connect this you
don't get an algorithm immediately you
you get the certificate that exists
exactly exactly exactly
thank you
[Applause]